- Hello Believe Nation,
today I'm going to talk about
the seven best habits
that you can have in life.
(techno music)
So one of the more common
questions that I get asked
is Evan, you do all this work,
researching famous entrepreneurs,
I want to know, what are
the consistent habits
that you find from all of these people
that we pull together
content from and research,
what are the habits that
you find equal success?
That if I do these things,
I will be more successful
in anything that I am working on.
So, I've compiled the
best of the best together,
to find the seven best habits
that you want to do to
succeed in your life.
(techno music)
Habit number one, is
ignore the little man.
- So many people I talk to at
that time for Alipay they say,
this is the stupidest
idea you have ever got.
- [Narrator] My father,
he said this is an embarrassment to me,
and was stomping all over me.
- I think every time I say
I'm about to do something,
people are waiting for me to fumble.
- I just can't live my life based upon
what other people think about me.
- Everybody tells me, you
don't need to do that man.
- Some people, would
rather kill your dream
than see you succeed.
- Oh, you don't understand
how hard it is to make it, Brendan.
It's so hard these days.
- Everybody told me, you're nuts.
You can't do that, you can't do that.
- And the people who are
like, offended by it,
it doesn't (beeping) matter.
- Don't ever let somebody tell
you you can't do something.
- Along your path of success
you're going to have a lot of people
who tell you that what you
want to do is not possible.
That it's just never
going to happen for you.
That you don't have
the skills, the talent,
the abilities, the drive,
the money, the resources,
the connections, whatever it is.
And some of those people will
just be jealous, straight up,
they'll be jealous, maybe they had a dream
that they wanted to chase,
and they weren't able to do it.
And so now nobody around them
is allowed to be successful.
They're going to try to always
pull you down to their level,
that's definitely going to be a chunk.
Some of the people who hate on your ideas,
and they're the little man,
they love you.
They're your parents,
they're your friends.
They just see success through their eyes.
So success for that person may be,
having a safe, steady, corporate
job for your entire life.
That's success, and doing anything else,
that's risky, that's dangerous,
you shouldn't go and do that.
And so they want you to live their life.
And that's their way of showing you love.
And so at some point in your
life, you need to figure out
if you're going to live
your version of your life,
or somebody else's version.
Whether you're going to live
up to your own expectations,
or you're living for
somebody else's expectations.
And when you have that self-confidence,
to say I'm living my version of my life,
then anybody else who's just
trying to knock your idea down,
not the one's who give you feedback,
not the one's who say,
hey, here's how you can make it better.
It's not just you have all the answers,
but the people who are
just hating on your idea,
and telling you you can't do it,
successful people ignore the little man.
(techno music)
Habit number two is think big.
- Think big.
- Thinking big.
- Thinking really big.
- Think bigger.
- Go big.
- Think big.
- Dream big.
- One of the things that
I've seen consistently
in the habits of successful people,
successful entrepreneurs,
is that they don't limit their thinking.
This ties to the last
point about the little man,
we have this vision for
what we want to accomplish,
a vision, what we think is possible.
The more that you can expand that vision,
the more that you can think
about having a bigger impact,
and take that little idea that you have,
that may be a huge idea
for your community,
right like, it may be the biggest thing
ever done in your family, or in your city,
and you want to take it even bigger,
the people who have the most success,
the people who have the biggest impact,
they're thinking on a different scale,
They're thinking on a bigger scale.
That's part of why I made this series.
I made the top 10 series,
I made the mentor me series.
All of these videos, is
because I want to be surrounded
by people who are thinking bigger,
to help push me to think
beyond my comfort zone.
Because I think for a
lot of entrepreneurs,
you're surrounded by people
who are small thinking.
And they maybe even say hey,
you're doing such a great job,
you know, look at all that
great work that you do,
and look at that big vision you have,
and nobody's saying, listen,
you're doing an okay job,
like this is really good, but
you could be playing out here.
You're still playing small,
you got to expand your vision.
You got to expand your horizon.
And successful people, think bigger,
and so I'd encourage you to look at,
is your vision big enough,
and when you have those
moments of boldness,
where you want to be out here,
do you then have the
environment around you
to support that big thinking
on a consistent basis.
Every single day,
not just one day all excited,
and then fall back down.
And the next month, one day all excited,
and fall back down.
Consistently think big.
(techno music)
Habit number three is no excuses.
- You just make an excuses.
- Don't become excuses.
- You can find the opportunities.
- Don't accept excuses.
- But we've got no time for excuses.
- I don't have an excuse.
- No excuses.
- No excuses, my friends.
- No longer wallow in my self pity.
- Successful people don't make excuses.
It's so easy to make excuses.
Most people blame somebody else,
for why they're not successful, right.
It's the President's fault,
it's my country's fault,
it's the education system's fault,
it's my parent's fault,
it's my friend's fault,
it's my bank's fault,
it's always somebody else's fault.
Right, it's easy.
It's always easy to put
the blame on somebody else,
'cause it makes you feel good.
'Cause accepting responsibility sucks.
Saying that your business
is not more successful
because of the customers, or the economy,
or whatever it is, is so much easier,
because it makes you feel good.
But it keeps you where you are,
and successful people,
the consistent habit that they have,
is they accept responsibility
and don't make excuses.
Your business is where
you are, because of you.
Your life is where it's
at, because of you.
Your bank account is the
size of your bank account
because of you.
And when you accept that, at
the start it sucks, right?
To say like, this really sucks,
if it's really because of me,
man, I suck.
But it's also empowering,
because you have the ability to change it.
You don't need to wait
another X number of years
for a new president to come in.
You don't need to wait
an X number of years
for the economy to get better.
You don't need to wait for anything.
You just got to get on yourself
and go make a change.
Successful people don't make excuses.
(techno music)
Habit number four is work hard.
- Work.
- Hard work.
- Working hard.
- Work hard.
- Hard work.
- Work harder.
- Work hard.
- Hard work.
For all the people out there
who are trying to build a passive income,
and are trying to work smart,
what you need to do is both.
You need to work smart and work hard.
If you look at the people
who've had the most success,
in whatever field,
whether it's in entrepreneurship,
or whether it's in at a relationship,
or whether it's being a parent.
You want to be a good parent?
You have to work hard at it.
You can't put being a
parent on auto-pilot,
and make it a passive
thing that just happens,
and expect to be a good parent.
You can't put your business on auto-pilot
and expect to be a great entrepreneur.
Whatever your goal is,
whether it's financial,
whether it's spiritual,
whether it's in the family,
whether it's with your business,
whatever impact you want to have,
whatever your big goal is,
you need to work at it.
You need to work smart
and you need to work hard.
You got to wake up, every day,
and go out after the
torture that you enjoy,
the thing that when people
look at your schedule,
they say, that's crazy,
how can you work so hard?
But for you, you do it,
because you want to.
Because you have an end goal,
and so, you have to be willing and able
to put in the hours required
to become really great at something.
In whatever field, again, that
you have your goal set out.
You need to work hard.
(techno music)
Habit number five is follow your passion.
- Passion.
This ties in with working hard.
You only will really work hard,
and put in the hours at
something you love doing.
You look at the top people in any field,
they love the work that they're doing.
They love it.
They do the torture because
it's not torture for them.
They love the work.
So many people are
attached just to a goal.
I need to make this much money, right,
I want to go buy that car, whatever it is.
I'll do whatever it takes to get there.
You won't do whatever it takes
because that goal itself,
is not important enough.
Because, the work itself,
if you hate doing the work,
you're never going to become a success.
You're going to quit.
You're going to give
up, because it's hard.
If it's anything worth doing,
it's going to be hard, it's
going to be a lot of work.
And the people who love it,
who don't see the work
as work, will keep going.
How many videos do I
make a week, how many?
I make so many videos a week.
I do it because I like making videos.
You will not be able to
keep up with my schedule
of making videos because
you don't love it as much.
Most people don't love it as much.
Maybe you're the rare
person that loves video
even more than me and that's amazing.
I'd love to meet you.
But, whatever your goal is,
it's great having a dang goal,
you need to enjoy the process.
Successful people enjoy
the day to day grind
of what they do because they
don't see it as a grind.
That doesn't mean that every
day is amazing and happy,
and all that your doing
is work that you enjoy,
there's a lot of crap that comes with it.
Being a parent, there's a lot of crap
that comes with being a parent.
But you got to do the work,
you got to put in the time.
You got to love your kids if
you want to be a great parent,
and the reward is definitely worth it,
over the pain that comes with it,
and some of the down
days that you'll have.
But successful people
follow their passion.
(techno music)
Habit number six is gratitude.
- I always felt grateful
for even the small things.
- Grateful.
- Be grateful.
- Being grateful.
- I think it's important
that you are grateful for
the things in your life.
I think entrepreneurs need to be
equally grateful for what they have
and wanting to do more.
You know, I look at if
my channel ends today,
I'd be really proud of everything I have.
I love the life that I have,
the friends that I have,
the family I have, the
business that I have.
I love it all, and at the same time,
I want to go out and do more.
Because I know I have
the ability to do more.
I want to reach more people,
I want to touch more lives.
I think too many entrepreneurs
are just so focused
on more more more more
more more more more more
It's kind of just this endless chase,
'cause you never get there.
Wherever you get, there's
going to always be more,
and always be more and be more.
And that drive is amazing,
and entrepreneurs have that in spades.
Just spending some time being grateful
for what you do actually have,
can help balance you out
and make you a much happier entrepreneur.
And I think it's needed, if
you want to have success,
that gratitude part I think is important.
I've had a success practice
in my life for a number of years.
It used to be I had my
pad of paper by my bed,
and I woke up every morning
and wrote down three
things I'm grateful for.
I've evolved that into
something I do with my team,
where every day they share something,
we all share something in
a private Facebook group,
that we are grateful for, for the day.
It also helps get to know
your team members a little bit more
and makes you realize things
that maybe you should be grateful for too.
If someone on my team says
they're grateful for the sun today,
you know I'm like,
look at the sun today, I'm
really grateful for the sun, too.
It adds some extra awareness for you,
and now we do it on the channel,
we've had live gratitude sessions as well.
Whatever your practice is,
making it a daily thing,
where you're grateful for what you have,
as well as being driven
to want to do more,
is an important habit for a lot
of successful entrepreneurs.
(techno music)
And number seven, is believe.
- Believe.
- Believe it.
- So you guys know, if you made
it to the end of this video,
if you watch any of the
videos on my channel,
you know I'm all about believe.
I think it's the core of success
in a lot of entrepreneurs.
You have to believe in the
work that you're doing,
you have to believe in yourself,
that you can go out and do it,
and you have to believe
that it's going to work out.
And, successful people have that
belief in themselves, that they can do it.
And not all the time,
'cause everybody thinks
about quitting at some point,
and that may mean you
need to watch a video
or read a book, or be around
friends that can help you,
build you back up to get to the point
where you have the confidence
to go out and continue to do it
but you need to believe
in what you're doing,
believe in yourself
and believe that it's going to work out.
And I would challenge you
that if you are that person,
to then, not just settle for that,
but also be the spark for other people.
If you see somebody else who needs
a little bit of belief in themselves,
and belief in their work,
just saying I believe in you,
without being able to give them advice.
Somebody wants to, you
know, start a makeup line,
and you know nothing about makeup.
Just giving them a little bit of a boost,
to say, you know I believe
that you can do that.
You're really talented,
I think you'll make it.
Just that little bit
can be the difference.
I remember when I first got
comments on my YouTube channel,
just a few comments coming in,
made me happy, made me feel like,
yeah, I'm doing something important.
And so, if you have that,
then give it to others.
If you go on somebody's YouTube channel,
leave them a comment.
If you see somebody around you
could use a little bit of a boost,
don't be afraid of, how
they're going to judge you.
Don't be afraid, give them that
little bit of encouragement,
'cause it can make a huge
difference in their life.
So that's my take on the seven
best habits that you can have in life.
I'm curious to know which
one did you like the best.
Which one did resonates most with you?
Please leave it in the comments below.
Also, did I miss an eight, nine, ten?
Something you want to add to the list
to make it an even ten, let me know,
leave it in the comments.
Finally, I want to give a
shoutout to Faruque Syed,
thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "Your One Word,"
it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you can continue
to believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.